selon le haut commissariat pour les
réfugiés le hcr
il y à 60 millions de déracinés dans le
monde 20 millions de réfugiés qui ont
été contraints de fuir au delà des
frontières de leur pays et 40 millions
de déplacés qui ont trouvé refuge à
l'intérieur de leur propre pays
aujourd'hui dans le monde une personne
tous les vins 122è soirée si déracinés
soient réfugiés en europe en 2015
1,2 million de personnes ont déposé une
demande d'asile
c'est 600 milles de plus par rapport à
l'année d'avant
la courbe que vous voyez sur ce
graphique est impressionnante
pourtant il n'y a pas de crise des
réfugiés en europe car un chiffre n'a
pas qu'une valeur absolue il faut le
mettre en perspective il faut
s'intéresser aux échelles à l'échelle
géographique et à l'échelle historique
mais regardons d'abord les chiffres je
suis d'accord avec vous 1,2 million de
réfugiés en europe
c'est beaucoup et on sait déjà que les
arrivées ne vont pas diminuer ces
prochaines années
mais savez vous combien d'habitants
compte l'europe 508 millions donc
l'année passée en europe
un demandeur d'asile chaque 500
habitants est arrivé visuellement ça
donne ça une étoile rouge diluée dans
une merde étoiles bleues et même avec
l'arrivée de six cent mille personnes
comme c'était le cas l'année passée il
n'y a vait l'année passée quand
demandeurs d'asile chaque 500 1 sur 1000
l'année d'avant regardons regardons mais
non l'échelle géographique
essayons de voir ce qui se passe au delà
de notre continent
je suis géographe je m'intéresse
quotidiennement à ces questions je
m'intéresse aux frontières et aux
mouvements migratoires
si on prend les statistiques dans le
monde on voit que l'accueil le poids de
l'accueil repose sur les épaules des
états les plus pauvres
en effet 86 % des réfugiés sont
accueillis dans les pays du sud
c'est cet arc des réfugiés déplacés qui
a été dessiné par philippe rekacewicz
saint marc qui va de l'indonésie à la
tanzanie
et même quand la guerre est tout proche
de chez nous comme c'est le cas pour la
syrie les réfugiés n'arrivent que très
rarement chez nous sur les 5 millions de
réfugiés syriens 2,7
aujourd'hui sont installés en turquie 1
million au liban au liban aujourd'hui
une personne sur quatre est réfugié
c'est comme si l'europe accueilli 120 5
millions de réfugiés
on en est très très loin alors oui il y
as crise des réfugiés mais pas en europe
l'europe n'est que très peu touchée par
cette crise pourtant l'europe a déjà
connu des crises de réfugiés entre août
et décembre 1921 quelques 1,5 million de
russes ont fui les famines soviétique et
se sont installés dans le monde en
europe en 1945 à la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
40 millions de déplacés et réfugiés ont
été accueillis en europe
plus récemment à partir de 1975 3
millions de boat people qui souffre qui
s'enfuyait
des colonies des ex colonies françaises
d'indochine sont accueillis quelque part
dans le monde y compris en europe
donc oui les déplacements forcés ça
toujours existé ce n'est pas un
phénomène nouveau
surtout l'histoire nous montre que
l'europe a su accueillir ces populations
fuyant les guerres et les conflits
aujourd'hui comme dans le passé on
efface un monde qui connaît de
nombreuses crises les guerres et les
instabilités politiques il y en a
beaucoup dans le monde
il y en a certaines qui sont proches de
chez nous c'est le cas de la syrie il ya
d'autres guère plus lointains et qu'on
connaît un petit peu moins
le yémen l'erythrée le soudan la somalie
l'ethiopie la libye la turquie
ce sont ces pays que vous voyez en rouge
sur cette carte
mais si dans le passé les réfugiés en
russie a trouvé refuge quelque part dans
le monde
aujourd'hui les portes se ferment on
érige des murs pour bloquer leur arrivée
comme on le voit sur cette carte
d'elisabeth valais on comptait une
dizaine de murs à la fin de la guerre
froide
aujourd'hui il y en a 70 qui sont
construits ou on voit on voit de
construction quarante mille kilomètres
de frontière aujourd'hui dans le monde
sont murées ainsi l'utilisation du mot
crise ne sert pas à décrire un phénomène
il sert surtout à fonder des politiques
et des actions parler de crise des
réfugiés s'est appelé à des mesures
urgentes et exceptionnelle s'est
justifié la fermeture des frontières
comme seul moyen de gestion des mobilité
humaine en augmentant les contrôles
frontaliers on oblige les réfugiés à
passer par des chemins qui sont toujours
plus longs et tout
au plus dangereux aujourd'hui des
réfugiés syriens pour pouvoir atteindre
l'europe sont obligés de passer par
l'arctique par la frontière russo
norvégienne ou par l'afrique de l'ouest
des réfugiés syriens vol en mauritanie
traverse le désert du sahara pour
rejoindre l'europe
je vous disais que ces routes ne sont
pas seulement plus longue
elles sont aussi plus dangereuse les
conséquences de la fermeture des
frontières sont devant nos yeux
à deux pas de chez nous là où on va se
baigner l'été en méditerranée il ya des
milliers de gens qui périssent depuis
1993 on a déjà identifié plus de 30
mille corps
on sait pour certains que ces chiffres
sont sous pression sous deux sont sous
évaluées c'est donc une crise
humanitaire
les obstacles physiques à la migration
sont eux responsables de l'augmentation
de la mortalité des routes migratoires
dans le cas des boat people vietnamiens
le hcr a mis en place un programme pour
la réinstallation les réfugiés
vietnamiens ont pu profiter de ces
programmes et ne pas prendre des routes
dangereuses pour arriver dans les
nouveaux pays d'accueil avec ses
programmes on a sauvé la vie à des
dizaines de milliers de vietnamiens
aujourd'hui on pourrait mettre en place
le même type de programme mais à la
place au lieu de mettre en place des
routes de fuite pour les réfugiés
somaliens erythréens ou syrien l'europe
et les autres pays occidentaux se
barricade
carte de philippe rekacewicz qui
illustre les dispositifs de
sanctuarisation des pays occidentaux
ils sont figurés par les dents rouges
sur cette carte en faisant si ces états
contreviennent à leurs obligations
internationales
car ne pas accueillir des réfugiés
c'est violer le droit international
la crise est donc une crise humanitaire
mais c'est aussi une crise des
politiques migratoires et une crise de
l'état de droit
merci